so Adam you play the villain kylo Ren
how did you feel about taking on the
role of the villain well I didn't think
of him as a villain that I guess we were
working on it I tried to through JJ kind
of hearing what he had to say about him
tried to hopefully make him as human as
possible so that's where I started I
guess where we started as opposed to an
end result we tried to think of how that
person began kylo Ren is a complex and
conflicted conflicted villain who wears
a mask how did you approach showing all
of these dimensions without the aid of
facial emotions
well someone that I guess is not really
up to me and some of it was you know
it's so collaborative that like you can
only do so much and just trust everyone
that the that the story is coming across
that you don't maybe you don't fight the
costume I guess there's so many trusting
that the power of thought is is there's
a powerful force to to use the custom is
powerful but also also like just getting
it on there's a lot of information and
then why why does that person feel they
need to cover themselves or be concealed
is also a lot of information you know
I've been trusting the power of thought
I guess that that all that that story is
still coming across even though you
can't be seen what was it like working
with JJ on fleshing out the character
very exciting he's couldn't be a more
calm
you know thoughtful collaborator who
that sounds like a line but it's it's
true or I've been in like his ability to
kind of compartmentalize and give
everyone their you know due attention
and with the still keeping a third eye
on the bigger picture is pretty
incredible to witness were you impressed
by the scale of the film and the
practical sets and how did that sense of
reality and authenticity help you as an
actor well just speaking of JJ he just
he understood that innately that putting
people in front of you know blue walls
wasn't it wouldn't be as exciting as
putting him people in front of like
tactile objects and how that also gave
him room for improv which was really I
think necessary in something like this
and I feel like you get that in the
original trilogy that even though it's
they were working within constraints you
know either either financial or you know
just technology and I think it allowed
them for a lot of improv and he set
himself up for that and with having you
know probably more resources but still
giving himself constraints which is rich
is good what kind of training did you
have to do for this part a lot of fight
training led uh which was which was fine
I mean these people are at war so it's
there they are very physical anyway you
know and that that kind of all informs
everyone's character I'd say what can
audiences look forward to when Star Wars
The Force awakens hits the big screen I
don't know I feel like that's a question
for them to answer what I feel like
everyone the strength of these movies
that they create so many worlds and
there's there's so much detail in them
that people kind of I hesitate to say
what people are gonna feel when they go
in and watch the movie but I think that
they'll hopefully find themselves
immersed immersed in a world that they
can take ownership of if you had to
describe your experience making this
film in one word what would that word be
and why
surreal self-explanatory so what made
you want to join Star Wars and play
Captain phasma oh good lord
what wouldn't make me want to join Star
Wars and and play Captain phasma I had
loved Star Wars since I was first shown
it I think I was around six years old
when my family showed it to me and I
fell in love with the film there were so
many unusual elements things that I
didn't feel I'd seen before in other
films I remember even at that very young
age seeing Princess Leia and being so in
a state of rapture due to her strength
her wit her determination and thinking
son usual I don't really see women like
that in the things that I watch even at
that very young age and thinking I like
it and I like her
and I want to be like her that was you
know I was thinking back about this
recently that was quite a significant
moment I also remember saying when I was
very little I want to be in a Star Wars
film and being told well they don't make
them anymore and so when I heard that
they were making them again this was
happening again and that JJ Abrams would
be directing I wanted to be in a more
than anything I'd really loved super 8
I'd really love what JD did with the
Star Trek movies I just felt like this
beloved series of films that this would
be in in safe hands and I really wanted
to work with JJ so when I heard that
they were they were going to be casting
for the films I was just like a dog with
a bone I would not let it go and I went
on and on and on about it for probably
about six months I went on about it
until finally probably someone just was
like gave in had enough can't take it
anymore and her and I was lucky enough
to get a meeting and after that when I
found out fully about the character and
about what the costume was and what this
character truly was then I was so
excited and I felt that it was such a
modern idea to have Captain phasma is
Star Wars first on-screen female villain
I believe and the idea that there is a
female character who is encased in armor
and we fought primarily form a
relationship with her due to her actions
and her character rather than the way
she has been made flesh was very
interesting to me and for there to be a
woman depicted in that way in a Star
Wars movie
felt truly progressive to me and I
realized quite how lucky I was how did
you approach bringing both femininity
and power to the role while wearing a
face covering stormtrooper helmet well I
didn't really think about bringing
femininity to the role I thought about
the character what the character was
there the list of characteristics things
that made up who the character was their
actions what other people said about the
character what the character said about
themselves and what I did focus on was
that I knew because there's so much
costume that went what went on below the
neck would be as important as what went
on above the neck so it became a very
creative acting challenge for me because
every gesture had to be explored and
investigated and every gesture had to
say something about the character had to
inform the audience who this character
walls so it meant that I had to do an
investigation of the way that the
character walked the way she stood and
where the emphasis would be in the body
and I am a woman wearing armor so I
didn't have to think about making that
feminine what was it like to be on set
surrounded by the Star Wars world and
seeing all the original cast it was
completely insane I could never have
expected this I said I don't think I
ever dreamed it when I heard that those
three iconic cast members were going to
be back in the Star Wars films I mean
everyone just breathed a collective sigh
of relief and a scream of joy and and
they've been so warm to me
and so encompassing the whole the whole
production everybody in the crew all the
creatives JJ Kathleen all of the actors
have been so enthusiastic
and so warm about this film and the
understanding that everybody loves it
and that it means so much to everyone
and it's been a real joy to work on I've
thoroughly enjoyed myself and and I
really couldn't have hoped for a better
experience to that point if you had to
describe your experience making this
film in one word what would it be and
why
mind-bending not really one word though
is it may be to can I have to thank you
I know it's greedy of me for you
personally what was the thing you liked
best about playing Captain phasma what I
liked best about playing Captain phasma
was that she felt knew this felt like a
different way to see a female character
in a movie it it felt like a different
way for an audience to form a
relationship with with a female
character and the fact that that was in
Star Wars really impressed me and
heartened me because it it seems like
there's been an upholding of those
original values of Star Wars all the
things that we love and we hold dear but
it's been brought right up to date and
into the modern day in a way that
everybody really seems to be applauding
so what attracted you to the role of
mass well what attracted me was first of
all the opportunity to play a motion
capture character I thought that gave me
a unique experience where I didn't have
that where I got to play a character
that wasn't limited by my physical
circumstances and that's something that
I wanted to do ever since seeing Andy
Serkis in Lord of the Rings as Colin and
then obviously Mars
herself I mean I felt I was attracted to
the heart of her and I was also
attracted to the questions that I
had concerning who she was and who she
might become in in in the in the movie
and thirdly I was attracted to this
project because JJ Abrams was directing
it and he is such a master at what he
does
passionate and empathetic and I was
looking forward to working with him
tell us about working in motion capture
for the first time what kind of
challenges did it present to you as an
actress well the thing about motion
capture is that Andy Serkis gave me some
advice he said go about creating this
character as you would any other
character which was a relief and then
there is the added challenge of working
with the technical aspects of it and
also the challenge of performing
something out of costume out of hair and
makeup you kind of have to imagine those
things and imagine how your character in
their physicality would experience space
and relationships so that was a
challenge but what is what I signed up
for and it was kind of weird walking
around with cameras in my face with
lights shining on me all the time
how did the real sets and creatures aid
your performance it was so helpful to be
a part of the principal photography I
know few motion capture characters get
that opportunity to be working with the
actual actors on the actual sets and
just take a step onto that Star Wars
those Star Wars War sets and to look at
the detail the detail that was put into
every single thing you see and how
everything was so practical I mean the
creatures walking around I would stand
on that set and just marvel at the fact
that I got to be a part of this universe
it is so helpful to have that offered to
you really what was it like working with
Harrison Ford and Daisy Ridley and John
boyega it was so much fun working with
Harrison Daisy and John we we had a good
vibes good chemistry I think and and
everyone was very supportive of each
other and very focused and and playful
as well which is always good last
question if you had to describe your
experience
making this film in one word what would
it be and why Wilde because never in my
wildest dreams wildest I am a Giunta
that Star Wars would continue thirty
years later and that Harrison Ford
Carrie Fisher and Mark Hamill would
still be a part of it and that I would
be in it with them I mean all that is
wild and then the process of making this
film with JJ and Andy Serkis I mean it
was surreal
you